hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es ist Tag 2 nachdem schrecklichen
Erdbeben im Süden der Türkei und im
Norden von Syrien das unfassbares
angerichtet hat mindestens 5000 Menschen
das ist heute klar sollen ums Leben
gekommen sein doch viele sind immer noch
verschüttet etliche Sinn verletzt wir
schauen in die Bilder Dienstag morgen im
Katastrophengebiet nach einer Nacht die
den Helfern alles abverlangt hat in
Aleppo in Syrien suchen sie suchen Sie
weiter in den Trümmern nach Überlebenden
und manchmal können sie noch Menschen
retten ganz in der Nähe graben sie ein
Kind aus dem Schutt aus Momente die uns
Hoffnung geben und auch in der Türkei
sind die Bergungsarbeiten eine
Riesenaufgabe tonnenweise Trümmer das
hier sind Bilder aus einem Wohnviertel
in Hatay ganz im Süden
international sind große Hilfsaktionen
angelaufen auch deutsche Teams sind im
Erdbebengebiet angekommen
und wir sprechen heute in unserer
Sendung Mithelfern vor Ort und auch
einem rettungsexperten ihr könnt Fragen
stellen im Stream und per Mail zuerst
wieder an unsere Reporterin an Anne
Brühl live in der Türkei sie ist in
göksun in der Region in der Nähe des
Epizentrums ganz in der Nähe hallo Anne
wie ist die Lage heute an Tag 2 vor Ort
[Musik]
ich frage noch mal nach bei einer
natürlich gehört hat
okay
natürlich auch nicht so einfach wenn man
genau das ist natürlich auch nicht so
einfach da jetzt im Moment einen guten
Empfang zu bekommen wir arbeiten daran
wollen hoffentlich dann also gleich mit
einer sprechen schauen aber erstmal uns
die Ereignisse des Tages an insbesondere
die rettungs- und Bergungsarbeiten denn
das darum geht es ja heute ganz ganz
besonders und wir schauen einen Bericht
zunächst mal zusammen von Michael
fellert violand
macht Platz lasst ihn atmen sagen die
Rettungskräfte es sind Momente wie diese
die den Helfern Hoffnung geben ein Mann
in der Provinz Karaman Maras wird
unversehrt aus den Trümmern geborgen
weiter südlich in der Provinz Hatay wird
am Morgen das Ausmaß der Katastrophe
sichtbar zerstörte Gebäude im ganzen
Land sind es tausende Berge von Trümmern
unter denen noch Menschen liegen
70% aller Gebäude sind zerstört es
stehen fast nur noch Ruinen
viele Menschen in Hatay verbrachten die
Nacht draußen in undichten Zelten in der
Region sei auch der Strom ausgefallen
die internationale Hilfe läuft bereits
auf Hochtouren die EU mobilisierte
bereits mehr als
1150 Rettungskräfte für den Einsatz in
der Türkei auch aus Deutschland sind
bereits Helfer in den
Katastrophengebieten angekommen
zDF-Reporter Anselm Stern hat sie
begleitet 40 Helferinnen und Helfer und
sieben Rettungshunde sind hier gerade in
giazentep eingetroffen und fahren jetzt
weiter ins Katastrophengebiet einer der
Einsatzleiter sagte vorhin in einer
Besprechung dieser Einsatz werde für die
Einsatzkräfte brandgefährlich die Lage
ist sehr kritisch die Leute haben sehr
sehr viel Angst die sind alle außer Haus
es fehlen in vielen Regionen natürlich
auch die Logistik aber man darf nicht
vergessen ist sind 10 Städte betroffen
ein sehr großer Umfang und das erschwert
natürlich sehr die Arbeit bei den
schlechten Wetterbedingungen ist hier
Arbeit auch für die Helfer ein Risiko
die Zeit drängt die Chance noch
Überlebende zu finden schwindet mit
jeder Minute
Leitung zu meiner Kollegin Anne Brühl
noch nicht steht können wir jetzt aber
mit einem Helfer vor Ort sprechen es ist
sehr Khan Ehren er ist von der privaten
Hilfsorganisation stellt jetzt in die
Türkei gereist ist auch schon angekommen
auf dem Weg auch Richtung Süden schön
dass Sie bei uns sind hallo
Herr Ehren sie sind jetzt oft haben sich
auf den Weg gemacht wir haben bei
Instagram in ihrer Story auch gesehen
das war gar nicht so einfach
Schneetreiben berichten Sie uns wie hat
das für sie geklappt erstmal zunächst
dorthin zu kommen wo sind sie gerade
ja es war ziemlich anstrengend
tatsächlich kam der Schneesturm zum
denkbar ungünstigsten Zeitpunkt wir sind
Istanbul gelandet und haben dann 12
Stunden gebraucht bis in den Südosten
und sind jetzt bei in Hatay direkt an
der Grenze
genau sie sind in Hatay die Region ganz
im Süden die besonders schlimm auch
betroffen sein soll schildern Sie uns
was Sie dort vor Ort schon erlebt haben
bitte
viele eingestürzte Gebäude hinter mir
und eine Fabrik sagt eine Wahnsinn drauf
Entwicklung also in allen Seiten äh
hinter mir sieht man Gebäude das erste
frisch eingestürzt ist also hat es
Erdbeben noch überstanden aber es
eingestürzt und so passiert ist hier die
ganze Zeit an ich will ja wirklich von
rauchen und geben hier gibt's kaum
jemanden der niemanden verloren hat also
egal mit dem man spricht man hört die
ganze Zeit mein Cousin gestorben mein
Onkel und also es ist einfach eine
einzige Katastrophe in Verbindung mit
dem Wetter super super wir haben jetzt
gerade tatsächlich ein ganz kurzen
Zeitpunkt erwischt wurde die Wolken
aufgegangen sind aber es hat ansonsten
hat die ganze Zeit geschneit man kann es
nicht anders beschreiben als er ja als
als einziger Katastrophe unsere Userin
Isabel Koch fragt bei YouTube eine Frage
an Sie welche Hilfsgüter werden in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen am
dringendsten benötigt
ganz wichtig sind Decken also decken ist
so die Prio 1 Ware weil
100.000 Menschen obdachlos sind also
entweder sind sie verschüttet oder sie
sind tatsächlich obdachlos weil niemand
traut sich mehr in die Wohnungen ähm
selbst die neuen Gebäude selbst da
braucht man sich nicht mehr rein wir
haben powerbanks besorgt wir haben
Wasser besorgt die
Wasserleitungen funktionieren nicht mehr
und vor allem Babynahrung und auch
Windeln ganz ganz wichtig und sie sind
jetzt heute angekommen haben Sie den
Eindruck außer ihnen ist schon viel
Hilfe da oder geht da wirklich noch mehr
sollte da auf jeden Fall noch mehr
gerade auch in den Süden ganz südlich
nach Hatay kommen
also ausländische Hilfe ist doch gar
nicht angekommen also habe ich doch
nicht habe ich zumindest noch nicht
gesehen ich möchte nicht lügen viel
türkische hilfe Also also aus dem also
aus dem türkischen Organisation habe ich
ganz viele gesehen aber es wird daran
liegen dass das die Organisation aus dem
Ausland das gleiche Problem hatten wie
hier wie wir wie gesagt Istanbul
angekommen und wollten auch hier die
Region fliegen äh das hat leider nicht
geklappt zwei Flüge wurden
gekennzeichnet sowieso nicht rein weil
die Flughäfen alle gesperrt sind und was
erleben Sie vor Ort gibt es Gerät um
eben Verschüttete zu bergen wie läuft
die Suche nach den vermissten Menschen
unter den Trümmern
die die staatliche ist völlig
überfordert man kann ihn aber auch
keinen großen Vorwurf machen weil es
einfach eine riesen diesen großes Gebiet
ist also man fährt wirklich hier durch
die Gegend und man sieht ständig
einstürzende Woche Häuser und also es
ist einfach eine Katastrophe auf einem
unglaublich bleiben Gebiet und ja
unmöglich zu stellen alleine also wir
hoffen dass äh ausländische Hilfe so
schnell wie möglich ein ankommt sagt wer
kann Ehren der mit einer privaten
Hilfsorganisation mit STEP vor Ort ist
und Gott sei Dank hat das auch geklappt
mit der Verbindung vielen Dank dass Sie
das möglich gemacht haben
sehr sehr gerne
die Verbindung zu meiner Kollegin Anne
Brühl die steht jetzt auch wieder sie
kann uns hören sie ist in göksun in der
Türkei in der Regionen ganz nah das
Epizentrums des gestrigen Bebens und
Anne auch an Dich natürlich die Frage
wie ist dort vor Ort die Lage bei dir
als wir hier in diesem Ort gorgzone
reingefahren sind haben wir viele
zerstörte Häuser gesehen die Menschen
hier sind ungefähr 53.000 die hier leben
sind eben in großer Nähe dieses
Epizentrums Caravan Maras liegt der ganz
in der Nähe und die Menschen beschweren
sich darüber dass die Hilfe kaum ankommt
gestern z.B wurden drei Kinder unter
trommern gerettet aber das haben
Anwohner hier im Ort gemacht die
Rettungsdienst das sieht man vielleicht
auch hinter mir die kommen jetzt
wirklich ganz langsam an da ist die
Abfahrt zu nennen das ist der türkische
Katastrophenschutz auf dem Weg hierher
über verschneite Bergpässe haben wir
viele LKW gesehen mit schwerem Gerät
Generatoren und das wird halt hier
dringend benötigt
das wäre meine nächste Frage auch was
hörst du von anderen Regionen des Gebiet
ist so groß das betroffen ist wie kommt
die Hilfe durch sind die Straßen frei
kommt das große Räumgerät durch
also hier in der Region in den Bergen
kann man sich vorstellen dass es hier
nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt aber
natürlich besonders schlimm weil auch
das Wetter so schlecht ist also es liegt
hoher Schnee heute Nacht gab es hier
Temperaturen von -10 Grad die Menschen
haben die Nacht in den Autos verbracht
und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch
verschüttete die in dieser Region weiter
unter den Trümmern liegen das sind
Menschen die mitten in der Nacht vom
Erdbeben überrascht worden
möglicherweise leicht bekleidet man kann
sich vorstellen dass man das nicht lange
aushält bei diesen Temperaturen die
Region ist ja riesengroßes sind zehn
Provinzen im ganzen Südosten der Türkei
und für diese zehn Provinzen das hat der
Präsident heute erklärt ähm Geld jetzt
für drei Monate der Ausnahmezustand
Einschätzung von einem brüllen live und
uns aus Götzen in der Türkei danke Anne
und aus allen Teilen der Welt sind
hilfsgruppen in die Region im Süden der
Türkei auch im Norden Syriens dazu
kommen wir auch noch zu sprechen im
Verlauf dieser Sendung über die Lage
dort vor Ort sind Hilfstruppen unterwegs
wir haben auch Bilder eines Teams von
Isar einer Hilfsorganisation denn die
wird von einem ZDF-Team begleitet die
sind auf die Rettung verschütteter
spezialisiert sie sind mit Spürhunden
auf dem Weg in der Nähe auch der
türkische syrischen Grenze sind da jetzt
gerade noch in einem Bus unterwegs
werden wohl bald ankommen auch dabei
sind Techniker mit speziellen Gerät um
eben Menschen in Trümmern zu finden auch
Ärzte sind dabei denn es ist ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
und auch Einsatzkräfte vom Technischen
Hilfswerk sind gerade auf dem Weg in die
Erdbebenregion und jetzt ist einer bei
uns der sich mit genau solchen Einsätzen
auskennt ist es Volker Strotmann vom THW
hallo schönen guten Tag
hallo schönen guten Tag Herr strutmann
wie viele Stunden ist dann überhaupt
noch Zeit um Überlebende zu finden das
ist ja die alles entscheidende Frage
heute
also die Faustregel ist normalerweise 72
Stunden das ist die Zeit wo man
allgemein davon ausgeht jetzt muss man
bei einer Schadenslage in dieser Größe
auch immer sagen es kommt darauf an wenn
Sie beschüttet werden in was für eine
Situation sie sich befinden wenn Sie
beispielsweise Zugang zu Wasser haben
was einfach eine Trinkflasche dabei
haben in der Nähe stehen hatten dann
können sie durchaus auch länger
überlegen aber nur die Regel ist 72
Stunden von dem man eigentlich ausgeht
und was brauchen ihre Einsatzkräfte vor
Ort eigentlich um so einen Einsatz dann
jetzt auch erfolgreich durchziehen zu
können also die sind die Gegebenheiten
denn da
also die Einheiten die wir schicken und
auch die Einheiten die die ganzen
anderen Länder geschickt haben sind
Einheiten die nach dem sogenannten
inserat-standard das ist ein Standard
der US ausgebrüstet sind die können
völlig autark agieren das heißt die
haben alles Werkzeug dabei was wir
brauchen wir haben Lebensmittel dabei
für sich selber sie müssen nicht
versorgt werden wir haben auch selbst
Wasser und solche Dinge dabei was
Getränke angeht wir können völlig
selbstständig dort vor Ort arbeiten
haben alles dabei was wir brauchen
können wirklich versuchen zu helfen ohne
dass wir vor Ort irgendjemanden zu
lassen fallen unter der uns versorgen
muss oder
wie gefährlich ist dann aber so ein
Einsatz auch für ihre Leute die sich
jetzt aufgemacht haben in der Region
das ist durchaus nicht ungefährlich weil
sie immer mit nachgeben rechnen müssen
und wenn Sie sich jetzt in trüb immer
Vorarbeiten um zu versuchen Menschen
noch zu finden oder verschiedene zu
bergen und dann kommt Nachbeben ist das
schon sehr gefährlich
in welche Rolle spielt das Wetter wir
haben ja jetzt mitbekommen in einigen
Regionen ist es sehr kalt das ist Schnee
Schneesturm Nässe Kälte welche Rolle
spielt das Wetter die Wetterverhältnisse
sind nicht günstig im Augenblick die
Kälte ist vor allen Dingen für die
Menschen sind sehr gefährlich und das
macht es nicht leichter
aber wir verstehen sie richtig es ist
jetzt noch Zeit 72 Stunden
und wir verstehen Sie auch richtig es
ist jetzt noch Zeit und
[Musik]
sagt Volker Strotmann vom THW vielen
Dank Herr Strotmann
dieses Gespräch wie auch unser nächstes
Interview und das mussten wir wegen dem
engen Terminplan von den Helferinnen und
Helfern an so einem Tag kurz vor der
Sendung aufzeichnen und das habe ich
kurz vor der Sendung also geführt und
eben auch das nächste Gespräch das ist
sehr spannend da geht es jetzt um die
Lage in Nordsyrien da wollen wir jetzt
auch noch mal genau hinschauen denn
gerade in diesem Gebiet in Nordsyrien
war die Situation vorher für viele
Menschen schon wirklich verheerend denn
in dem Land mangelte es schon zuvor vor
dieser Katastrophe an allem wir schauen
zunächst einen Bericht von Holi
die Rettung eines Kindes
seit Montag früh Bergen die
zivilschutzhelfer der weißhelme
überlebende und Opfer hunderte Familien
sagen sie sollen noch immer in den
Trümmern liegen
in Nordwest Syrien auch vor dem Beben
ein humanitäres Krisengebiet sind
Geschäfte mehrstöckige Wohnhäuser und
ganze Viertel eingestürzt ein Großteil
der Infrastruktur war bereits marode
durch Angriffe des syrischen Regimes und
der russischen Luftwaffe die meisten
Bewohner hier sind mehrfach Vertriebene
und Flüchtlinge 10000 haben jetzt wieder
ihr zu Hause verloren
der Verlust hat mich gebrochen ich habe
keine Familie ich habe niemanden mehr
sagt ein Einwohner Ingenieurs der 12
Menschen verloren hat
ein Krankenhaus in afrin in den Fluren
stapeln sich Tote
Ärzte berichten dass die wenigen kleinen
Kliniken der Region völlig überlastet
sein
in einem Flüchtlingscamp werden Gräber
ausgegraben für 30 Menschen berichtet
ein Augenzeuge
Aleppo in einem von Damaskus
kontrollierten Gebiet Treibstoff ist
seit längerem im ganzen Land Mangelware
viele Jura verbrennen Holz-
wir sprechen jetzt über die Lage in
Nordsyrien mit Marten Julius von der
Hilfsorganisation CARE hallo schön dass
Sie da sind
hallo schönen guten Tag Herr Milius was
berichten denn ihre Mitarbeiter von CARE
die vor Ort sind über die aktuelle Lage
in Nordsyrien
haben wir tatsächlich in Nordsyrien
Partnerorganisation die dort vor Ort
sind wir arbeiten da ja schon seit mehr
als zehn Jahren seitdem leider der
Krieger dort läuft die Situation ist
sehr
Verfahren also die Nachrichten waren
verzweifelt geschockt von unseren
Partnerorganisationen einfach das
Erdbeben war in einer Größe und das war
völlig unerwartet das hat man in
Jahrzehnten nicht gesehen und da sind
quasi in jeder Straße Gebäude
zusammengestürzt
Gesundheitseinrichtung beschädigt worden
die Menschen sind draußen geschockt
haben Angst
vor Redner ja schon gesagt hat es ist
sehr kalt es hat geschneitet - gerade
Mitarbeiter die tatsächlich von unseren
Partnern auch berichtet haben sitzen am
Auto es ist zwei drei Grad mit ihren
kleinen Kindern und so langsam läuft der
Sprit aus also wirklich eine ja sehr
doppelte dramatische Lage die sich da
abgezeichnet hat die wenn wir das
richtig verstanden haben ja auch vorher
schon nicht einfach war also
medizinische Einrichtungen die es schon
vorher nicht mehr gab die zerstört wurde
bei den Kämpfen in Syrien worauf kommt
es denn jetzt also für die Menschen vor
Ort am meisten an
also wirklich auch so die internationale
Solidarität die Menschen fühlen sich
dann natürlich allein gelassen sie haben
nicht diese Art der Infrastruktur wie
die in der Türkei zum Beispiel zur
Verfügung steht mit diesem
professionellen Katastrophenmanagement
ja die Gesundheitseinrichtung zu
unterstützen jetzt mit Medikamenten die
Menschen die draußen sind mit selten mit
Jacken mit warmem Essen das sind unsere
unmittelbaren Prioritäten und ja auch
den Menschen das Gefühl geben dass sie
nicht vergessen sind von von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft und ja wir
für Sie da sind unabhängig davon in
welchen Gebiete sie leben und unabhängig
davon von wem dieses kontrolliert wird
also man kann gar nicht sagen es gibt
die eine Region die es am schlimmsten
getroffen hat im Norden von Syrien ist
zieht sich da wirklich über einen großes
großes Gebiet
es ist ein großes Gebiet und es hat ja
auch viele
Nachbeben gegeben also dutzende
Nachbeben die dann in ein bisschen
anderen Regionen sich abgespielt haben
also über so einen ganzen
ja also großen Bereich und ja wir haben
das wir hören das tatsächlich aus dem
nordweste Syrien das wird jetzt immer
deutlicher wir sind viele Bilder wo
ganze Straßenzüge zusammengestürzt sind
wir hören die
Nachrichten aus Syrien also aus vielen
verschiedenen Gebieten innerhalb der
Türkei ist natürlich sehr offensichtlich
dass der Zugang natürlich wesentlich
besser da sieht man das viel klarer das
Bild aber ja es ist eine große Region
und sogar in Palästina und in Jordanien
wurden ja die erststöße und dem Libanon
da haben die Menschen das auch
wahrgenommen
vor Ort sind vor allem auch die
weißhelme im Einsatz und versuchen
Verschüttete zu bergen wir haben mit
einem Mitarbeiter der weißhelme mit dem
Chef der dortigen
in Syrien die Realität vor Ort sei
beängstigend sagt er und wir hören in
das Gespräch kurz rein
die meisten Menschen sind gerade auf der
Straße sie gehen zu den Zelten wo sie
sich vor dem eisigen Wetter schützen
können die Menschen brauchen Schutz sie
brauchen Hilfe Nahrung Medizin alles und
wir sehen nichts das nach Syrien kommt
mitten in der Katastrophe internationale
Straßen einige Autobahnen sind kaputt es
ist also schwierig wir brauchen
internationale Maßnahmen alle Mechaniker
die alles tun um die Zivilbevölkerung zu
unterstützen
wir brauchen alles Fahrzeuge wir
brauchen Unterstützung sofortige
Unterstützung Rettungskräfte
verantwortliche Teams für sofortige
Maßnahmen
quatschen wenn die Dinge so langsam
laufen dann brauchen wir Monate und mit
dieser Katastrophe fertig zu werden
und er sagt Monate um mit dieser
Katastrophe fertig zu werden befürchten
sie das auch
ja auf jeden Fall also die Situation was
natürlich da nicht einfacher der Zugang
diese fragmentationen sozusagen in der
Kontrolle der verschiedenen Gebiete wie
schwierig das ist Dinge über die Grenzen
zu bekommen und ja momentan das Wetter
die beschädigte Infrastruktur
all das sind natürlich Faktoren die das
sehr schwierig machen und zusätzlich für
uns würde ich noch hinzufügen dass es
natürlich eine besondere Situation ist
weil auch alle unsere Mitarbeiter wir
haben sehr viele Mitarbeiter vor Ort ist
fast eins unser größten Programme
weltweit aber sie sind selber betroffen
ihre Nachbarn ihre Familien verschüttet
die sind draußen auf den Straßen und
unsere Büros sind beschädigt die
Warenhäuser die gesamte Infrastruktur
und das macht es eben so schwierig und
das ist unsere große Frau
Herausforderung momentan und wir haben
von den weißen eben auch gehört das käme
nichts an woran liegt das
das ist vielleicht das Gefühl einfach
weil da ich mal das ist einfach eine
wahnsinnig große Katastrophe die eben in
so vielen Gebieten zur selben Zeit der
stattgefunden hat die Hilfe ist
angelaufen auch in Nordwesten Syrien wir
haben da große Programme wir haben von
unseren Partnerorganisationen von den
unorganisationen zu gehört überall ist
die Hilfe angelaufen weil es ja vorher
dort schon ähm sage ich mal Hilfe für
medizinische Einrichtung gegeben hat für
wir haben viele Kliniken unterstützt da
wir haben Schutzräume für Frauen und
Mädchen unterstützt natürlich haben wir
ein Lagerhäusern Decken Matratzen Zelte
und alles wird jetzt natürlich
dazu benutzt um den Erdbebenopfern zu
helfen aber angesichts der Größe der
Katastrophe kann ich mir vorstellen dass
das natürlich bei weitem nicht ausreicht
und das dann noch viel mehr passieren
muss
sagt Matten Milius von der
Hilfsorganisation CARE vielen Dank Herr
Müller
eine riesengroße Aufgabe wie uns Martin
Milius geschildert hat ich habe gelesen
in den Kommentaren dass ihr auch noch
einige ja fragen hattet zum Beispiel von
wandercani kam die Frage könnt ihr bitte
eine markierte Karte des Gebietes
einblenden das wollen wir hiermit gerne
tun dann mit einem auch mal ganz
deutlich wie groß die Region ist in der
das Leben gestern und auch die diversen
nachgeben es waren sehr viele Nachbeben
stattgefunden hat wir sehen es hier in
der Karte und zwar gab es einen Beben
ein zweites Beben
mitten in der Nacht und hier in Götzen
haben wir mit einem Brühl gesprochen
also auch ganz nah an der Region dran
und eben auch in Syrien ist
der große Teil des Nordens betroffen das
wollten wir euch gerne noch zeigen hier
sieht man es jetzt auch noch mal mit der
größeren Einschätzung dann gab es
weitere Fragen insbesondere natürlich
auch wie man helfen kann wie man spenden
kann Barbara Wolkow fragte sich ich
werde auch Geld spenden brauche aber
eine Bankverbindung und auch hier wollen
wir euch gerne natürlich die Möglichkeit
zeigen zu spenden und zwar gibt es vom
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe eben
eine Möglichkeit wie er den Menschen im
Erdbebengebiet helfen könnt wenn ihr
wollt und zwar ist dass die IBAN
de65100 400 600-100 400 600 das
Stichwort wäre dann ZDF Erdbeben Türkei
Syrien
und ich möchte auch noch ein paar
Kommentare von Euch Vorlesen die ich
auch gesehen habe was mich kurz schauen
wen ich mir hier noch notiert hatte und
zwar gab es hier einmal ein Kommentar
von Adam Schmidt der schrieb leider die
Familie meiner Frau hat alles beim
Erdbeben in der Türkei verloren also
auch einige Menschen hier einige User
und Userin in den Kommentaren die
betroffen sind und mevern hat schreibt
bei Youtube danke für die Hilfe und das
zusammenstehen denn darauf kommt es
jetzt an natürlich in den nächsten Tagen
vermutlich natürlich sogar auch Wochen
jetzt zunächst für euch nach der Hinweis
es gibt ein zdf-spezial heute bei uns im
TV und zwar um 19:24 Uhr wir berichten
also den ganzen Tag für euch weiter zu
diesem Thema jetzt zunächst mal danke
dass ihr dabei wart und bis dahin
tschüss